Let's look at these
two blocks here.
Block 1 has a mass of 3m and
Block 2 has a mass of 1 m.
And they're colliding
and sticking together.
And then they're going
to move in this direction
and eventually, slide onto
this rough surface here.
What we want to
figure out is, what
was that initial
velocity v0 with which
the two blocks collided?
So up to this part here--
before this x equals 0--
there's no external force
acting on the system.
So conservation
of momentum holds,
which means that p
final equals p initial.
So let's put this together.
We're going to have 3m v0.
That block goes in the
positive i hat direction.
Block 2 goes the opposite
way, so we have m v0.
And then at the end, when
they're stuck together
before here, we have to
consider only this portion here
that pertains to a
frictionless surface.
We have 4m v final.
And so the m's fall out.
This is 2.
This is 4.
So we'll see that the
final velocity is v0 half.
Now, in order to get
to this v0, we also
have to consider energy.
And in particular, we have to
use the work energy principle
here, because this joint
block is going to slide
onto this rough surface here.
So we can make use of the
work energy principle,
as we know what the initial
conditions are at this point
here, using the
conservation of momentum
from here in the first place.
So we want to use work equals
delta K, the work energy
principle.
Let's look at the work first.
Work is the integral
of F dot dS.
And we're dealing with a
one-dimensional problem
here, so we can
just write Fx dx.
And we want to have
this run from 0 to d.
I should say here that
this block eventually
comes to rest at x equals d.
We're going to use
that in a second.
So let's look at what this F is.
That's the frictional
force here at work.
And actually, which
direction does it go?
It opposes the motion fk.
So we're going to get a minus
sign here, integral fk dx,
again going from x prime
equals 0 to x prime equals d.
Now what is this fk ?We
know that fk equals mu k N.
And from doing a quick
free body diagram,
we'll see that we
have 4mg going down,
and we have a normal
force going up.
So we'll see that N equals 4mg,
which we can then plug in here.
And then that goes over there.
And the coefficient
of kinetic friction
is actually given to us.
So that nicely works out.
So we're going to have minus
integral x prime 0, x prime
equals d, the coefficient first,
b x squared, and then N 4mg dx.
If we integrate that, we're
going to get minus 4bmg.
And we'll integrate this one,
so that's x cubed over 3.
And we're going to plug
in this value here,
so we're going to get a d, and
that second term goes away.
So we are left
with d cubed here.
So this is our work.
And now we need to look at
the change in kinetic energy
between here and there.
We already know that this
block is at rest at x equals d.
So if the velocity is 0, our
kinetic energy will be 0,
and so our K final
minus K initial
is going to be
just minus initial.
And that's initial here,
which is the final situation
of our collision.
So we're going to look
at the combined block.
So we'll have minus 1/2 and
we have 4mv final squared.
We determined here already
that the final velocity is
the initial 1/2, so have minus.
Here we're going to have 2m,
and now v0 squared over 4.
And that actually gives
us minus 1/2 m v0 squared.
OK, so now we can put
this all together.
We apply this work
energy principle.
So we're going to get
minus 4/3 bmg d cubed
equals minus 1/2 m v0 squared.
We'll see that this and
this and this and this goes.
And so we're going
to get v0 equals 8/3,
and then we have bgd cubed
and the square root of that.
So this is our initial velocity
with which the two blocks
collided initially,
then eventually went
onto this rough surface and
came to rest here at x equals d.